influenceuse sur TikTok et chef de gang
d'un trafic de drogue au Chili Ina s'est
fait assassiner Sabrina Duran Montero
surnommée Ina était une influenceuse de
24 ans sur TikTok suivi par 550000
abonnés dans ces vidéos elle dansait
faisait des placements de produits et
utilisait le pseudonyme rakina kousman
une allusion directe au narcotrafiquant
roakin el chapo Gusman en prison à
perpétuité aux États-Unis car elle était
surtout une narcotrafiquante reconnue
Ina a été abatue mardi 24 octobre de
balles dans le corps par deux inconnus
probablement issus d'un gang rival les
forces de l'ordre chilienne se sont
mobilisé aujourd'hui pour les
funérailles de la reine du narcotrafic
la cérémonie est considérée comme à haut
risque la première arrestation dinina
liée à la drogue remonte à 2017 alors
qu'elle avait seulement 19 ans en mars
2022 les forces de l'ordre avaient saisi
à son domicile 655 g de cocaïne 7
millions de pesceau sans liquid neu
téléphones portables et une Audi A4 elle
avait été condamnée à 3 ans de prison
mais avait plidé coupable et pu être
libérée en mai